Let's talk a little bit about fundraising
in the 2020 campaign.
Incredible numbers from Bernie Sanders, the
independent Vermont Senator who is doing increasingly
well in recent polls.
Bernie Sanders raised $25 million in January
from 648,000 different people.
This is the most any candidate has raised
in any corridor in the election cycle period
and it may even be I was not able to confirm
this 100% 25 million in a month, maybe the
most raised by any candidate in any election
cycle ever in a single month, but fact check
me on that.
I'm not totally sure about that.
A teacher was the most common occupation of
people donating to Bernie Sanders.
The most common employers of the donors are
Amazon, Starbucks, Walmart, and the us postal
service as well as target.
Now, I don't know how much that really tells
us in the sense that these are just really
large employers and if you have a ton of employees
and there's a candidate that is resonating
with people, it sort of makes sense that there
would be a high number of individual donors
from that company.
Of the 648,000 donors, 219,000 were new donors.
These are people that had not previously donated
to Bernie Sanders.
Average donation is $18 and 72 cents almost
all of Bernie's donors reportedly just a hair
under 100% have not yet donated the maximum
meaning that depending on how the primary
process continues to play out, there could
be significantly more money coming from these
donors.
So a few things that I think are important
to talk about.
I find that the, the, the system we have is
disgusting.
Right?
You might be saying, David, how, why are you
talking about raising money?
Like it's a good, if you talk about the system
we have is terrible and we need money out
of politics.
Well until we change the game, you've got
to play the game.
That's very simple and I think like 98% of
my audience understands that it would be far
better that elections did not depend on fundraising
in this way or being able to, as Michael Bloomberg
is doing, pouring ungodly amounts of his own
money into this thing.
It would be great if we had public financing
of election.
It would be great if we made all of the reforms
to money in politics that we've been talking
about for a decade on the program.
But right now the candidate who raises more
money tends to win and it is a good sign for
the eventual viability of a Bernie nomination
if he gets it, that he is able to raise these
amounts of money.
So that's number one.
Number two, these amounts, uh, yes, these
amounts of money.
Number two, what is going to be Bernie strategy
as we get closer and into the super Tuesday
contention?
I've talked about how Michael Bloomberg has
made his strategy very clear.
He's pouring money into super Tuesday States.
Last week I told you I was visited by a Bloomberg
campaign staffer who came to my house and
uh, made it very clear that they are going
very, very hard in the super Tuesday States.
When we look at that strategy, it has been
working well for Michael Bloomberg.
He actually has hit 13 and 14% in some national
polls and is starting to climb in some of
those super Tuesday States.
So given the small number of delegates in
most of these first four primaries, when you
look at South Carolina being the one with
the most delegates, but that's the one where
Bernie is actually doing the worst in.
I would not be shocked if Bernie Sanders very,
very quickly transitions, particularly after
the New Hampshire primary on Tuesday where
he's doing really well.
I wouldn't be shocked if Bernie transitions
into a similar strategy to Bloomberg, which
is pour the money into super Tuesday States,
both in terms of advertising on television,
radio, online, YouTube, et cetera, as well
as campaigning in those States.
In a recall that if we look back at 2016 I
want to talk about the numbers a little bit
more.
In 2016 when it was essentially a two candidate
race, Bernie versus Hillary, Bernie raised
21 million in January this time with multiple
candidates that are at least potentially viable.
Bernie raised more $25 million.
Now you have to account for, there's a larger
population now and inflation and so on, but
that is an incredibly good sign for Bernie
Sanders.
Last thing.
One of the elements that is often glossed
over and it doesn't get as much attention
even though it is very interesting, is the
number of people that are making multiple
donations to Bernie Sanders.
He has a combination of new donors.
About a third of his January donors were new
donors who hadn't donated before, but 400,000
people that donated to Bernie in January had
already donated to Bernie before.
That is very important, particularly when
you look at Michael Bloomberg who has this
effectively bottomless pit of money.
Uh, but not nearly the support that Bernie
Sanders has.
It is really important that there are people
engaged enough that they are donating multiple
times.
It's terrible that this is the system.
It's a good thing that Bernie Sanders seems
to be doing so well.
Let's take a quick break, much more to discuss
afterwards